beiden liegt los und zwar mit vollgas in
den ersten stunden seiner amtszeit
korrigiert er die politik von donald
trump und gönnt sich abends eine kleine
party mit vielen stars natürlich digital
und seinem enkelchen auf dem arm und
donald trump der flug nach seinem abgang
aus roher schinken richtung florida auf
dem anwesen namens mara lago in palm
beach leicester ex-präsident alles
sacken mara lago so groß wie fünf
fußballfelder wert 160 millionen dollar
118 räume blattgold an den wänden zugang
zu einem privaten strand und natürlich
ein golfplatz in der nähe von oben sieht
man wie riesig das grundstück mit der
villa ist und dass es viele nachbarn
gibt und damit fangen die probleme an
die haben inzwischen genug von tram
grund die strengen
sicherheitsvorkehrungen führen immer
wieder zu staus und ramms helikopter ist
zu laut und nach malaga diesen ortes ja
anders statements wollen wir jetzt
direkt mal hinschauen katie pfleger
unsere kollegin ist dort vor ort katie
wie wird denn jetzt der neue derbe neue
permanente bewohner dort in florida
aufgenommen
aber es ist sehr ruhig hier momentan
also die transporte sind alle gegangen
weil man auch mal überhaupt nicht daran
kommt also man sieht jetzt im
hintergrund mara lago weil ich nicht mal
in die nähe von der insel fragen kann
die brücke wird abgesperrt
das ganze areal ist abgesperrt ist wird
von der wasserseite wenn man sieht wie
kostbar die homeland security die sogar
von der wasserseite absperrt also man
kommt überhaupt nicht in die nähe leider
und das ist natürlich auch für die
anwohner die direkt gegenüber wohnen auf
der schwierig weil sie teilweise zwei
stunden lang ab und an ihr haus nicht
verlassen kann
wegen diesen straße sperren was weiß man
katy darüber wie der ex-präsident ja
seine tage jetzt in malabo verbringt war
denn schon golf spielen aber noch nichts
also er ist immer noch dort normal und
ich habe gestern mit seinem golf
ausgesprochen ist da jedes war aber
während meiner präsidentschaft wolfen
gegangen jeden tag wunder hier war aber
momentan wieder sehr ruhig angehen um
nicht einfach noch mehr kontroversesten
schaffen um einfach gleich einen tag
nach der amtsübergabe auf dem golfplatz
gesehen zu werden und ich danke das ja
auch einfach sehr viel administrative
dinge immer noch zu tun hat auch wenn
die franzosen schafft jetzt vorbei ist
danke ich will es ja immer noch am
arbeiten und erst mal das schon für die
nächsten tage
also im moment offenbar totale ruhe rund
um job für den us präsidenten
gibt es irgendwelche besondere
vorkommnisse sonst drumherum noch
irgendwelche fans von ihm alle wirklich
zu hause will niemand mehr von ihm was
wissen
es ist also die ganzen chance vor davon
abgeraten denke ich weil man einfach
nicht mehr ankommt und die kommen auch
meistens nur wenn er wirklich mit der
autos kolonne durch wert weil man dann
die chance hat ihn zu sehen
aber er wird jetzt erstmal ein paar tage
dort in marokko einfach und sich aus der
öffentlichkeit auch ein bisschen
zurückzuziehen
die anwohner mit denen ich gesprochen
habe sei er sehr sehr genervt weil sie
einfach in ihrem park ging ich neben
eingeschränkt werden durch diese
sicherheitsvorkehrung also man muss sich
das so vorstellen
die straße vor dem lago ist mit 2 300
service mitarbeitern am umstellt das ist
meist nicht mehr so viel als er
präsident war aber immer noch und
kammerrat und diese straßensperrung
anwalt ist einfach eine stunde bevor er
das haus verlässt mittag werden die
straßen gesperrt und eine stunde danach
und dann die autos ihr einkommen wieder
zurück auf die insel müssten ein
security check durchgehend das auto wird
untersucht und wenn man natürlich direkt
gegenüber wohnt man hat das zweimal am
tag dann ist das natürlich nicht so
angenehm
also mal lage gleicht einem
hochsicherheits gibt es ja die anwohner
sind schwer genervt die vielen
herzlichen dank für deine einschätzungen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
weil bild schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergessen nicht zu
abonnieren